In this video,
we come back to the formula of the determinant of a matrix.
What will this be equal to?
What will be the formula if we have the first row as the reference?
The first element 'a11'
will be multiplied with something.
Now this something is very important.
For the sign here,
we multiply it with 'minus 1'
raised to the row number plus the column number.
As 'a11' lies in the first row and the first column,
we raise 'minus 1' to '1 plus 1'.
And to find out what this is multiplied with,
we exclude the row and the column of 'a11'
and write the determinant of what remains.
Determinant of this will equal 'a22 times a33'
minus 'a23 times a32'.
This will be the first part of the formula.
Two more elements remain in the first row,
'a12' and 'a13'.
What will 'a1'2 be multiplied with?
'Minus 1' raised to 1 plus 2,
multiplied by the determinants of these four elements.
'a21' times 'a33'
minus 'a23 times a31'.
And what will 'a13' be multiplied with?
Pause the video and write the correct product here.
This is what we will have.
'Minus 1' raised to '1 plus 3' times this determinant.
We knew this formula,
we just saw it in a bit more detailed fashion.
Now there are a couple of terminologies
we need to be familiar with.
For the element 'a11'
this part here is called the minor.
Yes, this is a minor of 'a11'
and this entire part is called the cofactor of 'a11'.
Yes, this is the minor of 'a11'
and this is the cofactor of 'a11'.
Similarly, this is the minor of 'a12',
and this is the cofactor of 'a12'.
For 'a13' this is the minor and this is the cofactor.
A good way to remember this is by knowing that minor means small,
the smaller part is minor
and the bigger part is the cofactor.
Every element in the matrix has a minor and a cofactor.
So let's zoom out and find the minor and cofactor of 'a32'.
The minor is the determinant of what's left
after excluding the row and column of that element.
For 'a32',
we eliminate the third row and the second column.
The determinant of these four elements will equal
'a11' times 'a23'
minus 'a13' times 'a21'.
This is the minor of 'a32'.
For the cofactor
we just multiply this with 'minus 1' raised to '3 plus two'.
This will be the cofactor of 'a32'.
'Minus 1' raised to '3 plus 2' times this.
So can we derive a relation between the cofactor
and minor of an element in a matrix?
Yes.
What will be the cofactor of 'Aij' where 'i' is the row number
and 'j' is column number?
Remember, this multiplied by the minor gives us the cofactor.
So cofactor of 'Aij' will equal 'minus 1'
raised to 'i plus j' times the minor of 'Aij'.
This is the relation between the minor and cofactor of an element.
The minor is the smaller determinant part.
And multiplying it with this gives us the cofactor.
We will look at an example in the next part of the lesson.